[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the new rockstars live show streaming
right from our uh official break room
here at rockstars hq now we had a whole
show planned and then something dropped
uh that delayed the beginning of the
show that we've gotta both watch and
talk about immediately and that we got a
new full trailer for she-hulk
streaming on disney plus later this year
uh and we are going to uh live react to
it i've seen it because i'm a spoiler
nasty freak but none of them have and so
they'll all be giving their authentic
reactions and i'll be giving my canned
very fake reaction uh producer john can
you
play that trailer
play my friend
being a superhero
is a trial by fire
who's gonna protect the world it's not
people like you
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm jennifer walters i'm a lawyer i have
great friends can we get some shots
please it's an emergency a demanding job
we just started a super human law
division and i want you to be the face
of it
and a frustrating family because we
didn't ask for this
but you still got to deal with it your
transformations are triggered by anger
and fear
those are like the baseline of any woman
just existing
oh
i feel like if i don't transform i'm
gonna die
yes yes yes
no no
i just want to be a normal anonymous
lawyer can you tell us where she-hulk is
jen you're a story now
girl your ass looks crazy right now
you could be an avenger oh i'm not a
superhero
that is for billionaires and narcissists
and adult orphans for some reason
[Music]
is there anything more depressing than
dating in your 30s
yeah this is the best date i've had in a
while oh should we split some fries
let's get those to go
ready for this i'm going to dress up as
her 24 7. and now we should say uh eric
voss is going to be dropping a reaction
to this probably shortly after the break
room is done and we'll have a full
breakdown of this finding every easter
egg detail missable thing uh probably
tomorrow on the channel but for now
we're just going to give our uh very
green very uh very green very green
reactions to it oh yeah
things that stand out uh i liked what i
saw
and i'd love to say more about that
but every time i give an opinion i get a
shock from san francisco
and i'll have my thoughts on tommy's
time tomorrow on the break room tommy's
time yeah i have like a thousand
questions like why is hulk just smart
hulk still is he not transitioning yeah
is this before shang ji uh also what was
that big building is that like sword is
that d-o-d-c
i also i was oh no no no you have
something to address because i have
nothing to add to his oh i did i did
that one yeah go ahead no no no no god
we're too polite oh okay i'm sorry uh
i was gonna say that i'm more excited to
see she's training to be hulk where hulk
is like originally like just like i
don't know how to control this it's like
she seems like she's gonna control it
very easily and she's not afraid to show
off who she is so i'm very excited yeah
i love the fact well no you go ahead
tommy well all i was going to say is i i
am slightly relieved just my initial
reaction there had been a lot of rumors
going around that this was almost going
to be like a complete sitcom
and i thought and you know i can't
obviously you know we're not allowed to
talk too much about you know when you
audition for things i auditioned for
this show and the script that i
auditioned with which i'm sure was fake
and you can't talk about the books they
always give you fake lines for any of
like the the disney plus stuff because
they just want to see if you can act
obviously i can't because i didn't book
it but uh it did feel very sick comey so
i was i thought that there was some
credence to that and i am relieved just
as a viewer and as a marvel fan that it
appears to be kind of more of a strength
they decided to go with tatiana and
maslany over there
tim roth reprising his role i thought i
was in the haunted house
well and speaking of which i don't think
this is spoiling too much right we see
tim roth there he's playing abomination
now that's a de-powered abomination the
abomination we've known in the mcu is
not a go back and forth kind of
character always stays monstered out the
last time we saw him in chongqi fully
monstered out so we're saying are you
thinking this is the monstered out no we
saw the actual actor tim roth no no no
that's what i'm saying do you think
we're going to see him get monsters we
also saw a clip of him as abomination at
the very end where he watched some kind
of i was honestly i was hooked on
she-hulk the entire time but i kept
being like look at how great she looks
she looks because i was when she first
got casted i was very nervous from
reading like some marvel comics and
seeing she-hulk be like the like
strongest buffest bodybuilder woman on
the planet i was like oh i'm kind of a
great actor and just give her a
bodybuilder body right i mean all the
bodybuilders can't be great actors
[Laughter]
that wasn't me even flexing i do love
that that final shot of her cradling her
tinder date yeah
i've done that before besides besides
the loki on loki kiss is that maybe the
sexiest disney plus moment we've got oh
disney plans we did have luke cage to
the library recently and there's house
scene with jessica jones
uh oscar isaac's in the hotel room in
his skivvies
when he's drunk and sad hey
i've been in a few hotel rooms with
oscar isaac and he's just in his
underwear he's just a fart machine we
didn't see him door closed we know
you're all about
i think again the the show it's a lot of
action in that i do a couple things that
stood out to me i love that bruce banner
is back on some kind of tropical place
right the first time we saw the mark
ruffalo version of him when um black
widow is going to retrieve him in the
first avengers movie he's in like a
tropical india or something like that
looks like he's on a nice island now he
also loves he has a murder chamber that
he keeps in his lap yeah i think it said
stark on the song maybe they're like a
star but there's a stark saw that's not
repurposed woodworking
murder champion yeah yeah somebody made
that for a very specific again now we'll
also give this the caveat that um
disney plus upfronts are taking place
right now that's that's how we got this
trailer if another one happens while we
are broadcasting live we're gonna try to
cover it producer john will will rush in
sweaty and panicked and uh hold up a
laptop or something like that for us to
look at cassie and andor or secret
invasion or who knows what maybe just
like a new uh mr toad's wild ride teaser
you know we all would love to return to
hell with mr toad right that's right
yeah
isn't that where you go in that ride
yeah you're going
to write in i mean a lot of people would
argue the weight to get on the ride is
the rule
of hell uh
now we intro the actual
episode i'm zach edelstein i'm here with
my good friends and co-host mr brandon
barrett oh uh jessica clemens and the
the mr toad to my mr weasel uh tommy
bechtol so great to be back guys uh you
know we were in good hands yesterday but
brandon and i simply we couldn't wait
another day to come back i was gone for
a few days i had some things to take
care of yeah and i saw some stuff went
down while i was young yeah well didn't
you leave because of the haunting that
was happening well i can't say why i
left uh i was dealing with some things
and they have been taken care of i will
say the murderer appeared to have long
hair it wasn't me wow okay
beautiful long hair i only think of one
person
maybe if you watch the entire uh episode
today you might get some answers in some
of those riddles but uh some other
things you're going to get on today's
episode we're going to be talking about
the secret invasion series we're going
to be talking about some other doctor
strange cameos that got axed we've got
some aquaman 2 drama we've got some john
watts
star wars news and uh
and dish out some echo news all kinds of
stuff yeah coming up uh but first of
course we remind you that um here on the
break room we have a reverse swear jar
okay now that's not uh where you swear
and you get money you take money out of
this that's too dang bad when we hit a
hundred dollars in super chats which
we're so thankful for everybody that's
throwing out uh currency uh to thank us
um when we hit 100 in the swear jar it
unlocks a single swear that whichever
host happens to notice it in the moment
gets to unleash uh upon you the viewer
otherwise we do not curse i can't
friggin wait for that swear jar to fill
up like heck tommy watching the swear
jaw like a hawk i know this guy he's
he's an eagle eye on that he's a swear
jar sniper um hair just yes so we'll be
watching that and again we'll uh thank
you for everybody's super chatting we'll
we'll try to come back to the um to the
chat in the super chat near the end of
the show yeah i have a little q a if as
we're talking about different news and
items if something sparks your curiosity
throw that chat in there and we'll try
to get to all of that and we wanted to
thank our our number one super chatter
from yesterday i believe it was paint
and manetti yes yeah thank you for that
you unleashed uh a really nice deluge of
profanity myself and almost yeah almost
a song of profanity
there's a lot of star wars news coming
out uh kathleen kennedy dropped
a nugget-filled interview with variety
right that's right uh and we're going to
try to dissect some of those uh those
pieces of news but first uh we've got
some marvel news we got our first image
and show description for echo
the kind of quasi-hawkeye sequel
series coming up on disney plus there it
is
there's our uh alaqua cox as echo and we
know that we got a kind of brief
synopsis of the series
said the show revisits maya lopez as she
tries to escape her ruthless behavior in
new york by returning to her hometown
she must face her past reconnect with
her native american roots and learn to
trust friends and family if she has any
chance of moving forward
now no mention of any other mcu
characters that might be popping up in
there but we can assume so yeah but
there are a lot of it seems like there
are a lot of native american actors
joining the cast which is exciting to
get a little bit uh more um
diversity and exposure in kind of an
area that's been ignored by the mcu
whether purposefully or not i'm sure
accidentally probably get pieces of
wilson fish yeah yeah that leaked
not leaked or there was a leak no it
wasn't a leak it was the resume of the
costume designer she put on there that
she did the costuming for the actress
who plays echo
and also for wilson fisk and daredevil
on the show oh that would be great i
think we'll definitely see kingpin on
that show daredevil i don't know but i
think it would be really cool because as
a reminder the last time we saw echo she
was shooting wilson fisk in the face
she left she ran now it could also be in
flashbacks yeah she has a lot of history
with uh wilson fisk kingpin so maybe we
just see some flashbacks i can see
wilsonvisk still coming back for yes
and i think that synopsis kind of hints
at that like she tries to get away from
her dangerous new york history but it
follows her
is echo a target for like val does val
want to return oh
yeah
that would make a lot of sense it seems
like you know kind of crossing over
some questions write it in the chat
i i imagine what they were going to
possibly do with the thunderbolts is now
probably being taken over by val would
you say like kind of yes
i kind of mentioned yesterday william
hurt sadly the actor passed away in real
life so maybe yeah the in in the mcu as
we know it uh val julie louis drives
this character is maybe gonna be the
shepherd for that that group as opposed
to the comics version that thunderbolt
ross was often kind of the leader um in
an interview with publication xavi or
website xavi miss marvel star iman
valani uh says the upcoming show uh
starting later this no in june um the
show really embraces the coming of age
vibe saying it's like uh john
hughes-esque mixed with lady bird and
scott pilgrim that's name dropping some
pretty nice yeah
those are all kind of innovative there
um it's a lot more lighthearted than the
other shows we showcase that being a
teenager is awkward corny and weird
mm-hmm
i think anybody for some people not for
me i turned i turned 13 i got this great
beard
this banging body you're only you're
only 15 right you're 14 and a half
you're not legally supposed to be here
uh you can't even be on our discord so
oh i'm not on the discord i was removed
by the mods
for very good reason a long time ago
i've been reading um miss marvel
recently and that sentence alone is
completely what the series is it she is
so awkward and her group is just a bunch
of corny like 15 17 16 year olds yeah i
don't know i skipped but it like it's so
good it's so good and i can't look i i'm
now looking so much forward to this and
certainly her her referencing scott
pilgrim makes sense in that trailer
footage we've seen that has kind of like
cartoony animations interspersed with
the live action it'll be really
interesting to see what that that series
looks like gonna be lovey-dovey if it's
anything like that thanks maybe i mean
that paired up with uh that she-hulk
carrying her date i mean this could be a
horny summer for example
i think
there was a super chat um
charlie 836 that would ask if jess
you're probably xcx carry him like
she-hulk oh
maybe young men and young women who
haven't thought uh sexually in a certain
kind of way that yeah i might start
thinking my partner was a gigantic yeah
i can carry i can carry a man that's six
foot seven i can carry anyone all right
i am upcoming mandatory fun
[Applause]
i carry each of you on my back please
quickly calls my mom to ask her how tall
i am
mommy is
xavier in the chat tim roth will be the
only okay never mind i'm not going to
finish reading it come on save here come
on i think seriously or is it javier
yeah
you need i will not reiterate again i
mean it's our jobs to read comics here
so we can bring it to you without you
even having to read it but the 2014 miss
marvel is so fun and such a quick read
that you need to read it and then watch
the series it also is like if you're not
interested in like coming of age kind of
stuff like that then ms marvel might not
be for you because this is a a young
woman that's of color coming of age with
super powers and you know what that's a
great point i think we're now at the
point where marvel's making so much
content especially with these disney
plus series they're not all going to be
for you because there's a variety but
guess what they're making like six
series a year so if four of them are for
you yeah that's a pretty good batting
average you can just ignore the other
two and re-watch hawkeye or re-watch
loki yeah you can't stand to watch a
whole episode on disney plus come on
down to the break room and we'll cover
it for you guys we'll put in those
digestible little birdy fake room bites
and then
put them in your mouth spit them in your
mouth
we got a trio of unconfirmed doctor
strange two related cameos that came out
this this week um
these are rumored we don't have
confirmation from the production team uh
but first uh there was reportedly plans
for a ghost rider fight scene
that got cut out we don't know who would
have been playing ghost rider uh
supposedly wait what what yes what yeah
and now and we don't know how early this
was this could have been the storyboard
stage right well i suspect that there
was a version of this movie that dealt a
lot more with the kind of demonic like
testing the levels of like what you can
do from like those hell demons that were
like doctor strange or steven strange
you know you're breaking the law oh yeah
exactly but i wonder if maybe like at
this point they were going to establish
that like ghost rider was like in hell
and sent from hell to like you know
maybe stop strange or stop wanda from
you know maybe uh doing something that
mephisto or one of the other you know uh
demons didn't want them to officially
confirm i'd say memphis though tom firm
uh but uh yeah and again as we we've all
mentioned on this show before
just because you cast ghost rider
doesn't mean you cast an actor if you
have him in just rider mode just give
him a flaming skull and maybe uh michael
clark duncan kind of voice whatever um
michael fassbender was uh supposedly
said to reprise his role as magneto now
maybe you don't need him if you already
got charles xavier patrick stewart so
maybe that kind of makes sense that they
didn't uh burn him he also might have
been a backup if patrick stewart was
like mad because
patrick stewart had talked about it he's
like kind of iffy on it right yeah but i
and i i think you know it seems like
more and more what came out is they
weren't sure who that illuminati was
going to be for a long time and they had
a lot of different like maybe it'll be
this combination maybe it'll be this
combination yes i think what they
ultimately settled on was really cool
yes absolutely i really quickly want to
go to the super chatter and okay
said uh because it is actually a pretty
important and very nice question of like
i believe
the currency the chatter is alison
becker
what
oh sorry allison becker mentioned can
you really
where is it it's like oh can we really
ignore series when it's connected to the
whole mcu and i don't want to be the
person to say this
but you can
so you give me caps they give us
they give you not only do they give you
recaps but for someone that like me i
read the comics yes but there is a long
time for me to actually watch a lot of
the marvel series it took me so long to
watch daredevil i know that isn't
completely an mcu now but there's some
mcu things that you can especially
having people like us that keep up to
date for you you can be like i don't
really want to watch this and get the
notes the spark notes from us from us
and from eric foster the official new
rockstars platform is watch whatever
disney plus series you want always watch
the breakdown
i'll give you sparks all of our content
doesn't matter if the actual original ip
you consumer not tommy just had a
technical issue uh no no return to the
charlie horse though right thomas i
pissed myself oh yeah no i've been
horse-free uh that's charlie horses and
heroin for
uh ten days that's the trickle horse
yeah trickle horse um oh and then
finally the third cameo that was
supposedly planned at some point was
deadpool was gonna show up in a
post-credits scene yeah and what and and
multiplayer's madness
can you imagine if that's right pizza
papa finishes punching himself and says
it's over and they just pan over and
there's a mask
you know wade wilson just being like no
really yeah yeah oh yeah he just
continues hitting them
[Laughter]
uh it would have been fun but it also
makes sense that they may be waiting a
lot of this too could also be we saw
this in chongqi right they have those
pre-visualizations those artist content
and they'll just throw characters in
there because they're like i just have
to draw someone and they haven't even
written the script yet so someone might
have seen one of these and been like oh
they're bringing back michael fassbender
but who knows very much one of those
wouldn't it be cool if right yeah very
cool well what also was cool this week
samuel jackson he's been talking about
playing nick fury on entertainment
weekly's awardest podcast uh he revealed
that working on secret invasion he
learned things about nick fury that he
didn't know before uh things say he he's
been playing nick fiore since the
beginning yeah
they've been kind of going more into his
backstory and who he is uh and so he's
learned a lot about the evolution of
this character or he as he says the
de-evolution of this character is this a
mario brothers thing is he getting going
down i don't know
uh that was a 30 year old movie
reference right yeah
but he the main point he was making on
this podcast was like this is a great
way to dive deeper into what's going on
in secret invasion through nick fury we
have a clip if we can play that for you
guys
there are things that uh even
i really didn't know about nick fury
that i just found out the minds behind
what happened during the blip
are
you know fantastic uh because you know
that's part of what you know we're
uncovering when we do this series now
giving me an opportunity to
explore something other than the
badassery of who nick fury is you know
and i've had a good time doing that and
i'm looking forward to people you know
sharing that aspect of who he is when
this series does happen
we'll talk about what nick fury has to
say about the blip but first what
variety article did nick fury or did
samuel jackson find so important to cut
out and hang on the wall he must have
been in variety a thousand times
i think it was probably an article about
when i was cast on glee
they're probably like glee cast uh young
uh 30 year old newcomer yeah i wonder if
that was like his first variety mention
yeah oh maybe maybe yeah oscar this year
they didn't show it on the show but they
finally gave him an oscar
maybe it was for that but when he
finally got an oscar didn't you get an
oscar before i don't know
they didn't know i didn't watch the
oscars this year and i guess this was
the year to watch him but
are you telling me that he they didn't
show him get the honorary they did it in
the
pre-show this is so stupid what are we
even doing get out of here come on back
so that's what's most fascinating to me
nick flurry got nick fleury nick fury
god
we saw him get blipped in infinity war
in a post-credits sequence he's holding
the pager to call captain marvel he
tries to slip in a mother effer we can't
afford it yet uh but he gets booped he
gets dusted does it confirm this isn't
one of his fake deaths that he loves to
do so much
uh like in uh uh
winter soldier where he fake dies he he
actually got blipped so what could we
possibly learn about nick
fury during this blip if he's not there
what is so fascinating about it well i
do love and you know samuel l has done a
lot of press for marvel's stuff in the
past because he's been a part of the mcu
since almost the beginning so he's savvy
at not trying to spoil anything or not
saying anything he's not allowed to say
i but i couldn't help but over dissect
he did say the word fantastic yes just
saying uh i also love like we were
saying
devolution
i'm not sure maybe somebody in the chat
could say i've always thought it was
de-evolution is devolution an actual
word and if so is that mephisto
confirmed
the fantastic thing is interesting right
does a mr fantastic show up and bring in
a nick fury from a different dimension
thinking that the blip will never get
undone the blip gets undone and one nick
fury has to die yeah
so one can live it's like
it's like um the prestige you can't have
all those jackman's running around yeah
they got to kill those two jackman
that's a spoiler for a 20 year old movie
for you guys
hey
uh there's a lot of references i do not
get on this show oh no
i grew up with yo gabba gabba instead of
mr
rogers no one cares
jessica do you think it's possible that
someone brought nick fury back from the
blip before everybody else oh that would
be really sick all right the thing is i
would love that i would love it but i
don't think it's okay i don't think it's
gonna actually happen but i would love
it i'm gonna ask you a question because
maybe i'm just a little dense sure does
secret invasion take place during the
blip no
not that we know of but we've we've been
theorizing that like the blip is a great
time for some evil scrolls yeah and
impersonate people that were blipped
away very easy to slip in well i have a
thought
what if nick fury was like so savvy that
he had like
15 scrolls all playing
so the nick fury we saw blipped was
actually a scrawl wow
but he never came
all knew about the pager and was allowed
to carry the pager he was the most
trusted scroll he was the most trusted i
mean talos impersonating fury had to
have been clued in that was an
authorized impersonation right fury was
fine with that he probably like gave him
a certain degree of security clearance
told him some stuff that he would know
so maybe that was something they've
always had he's known at that point he's
known talos for 30 years right so i
really trust this guy and possibly talos
slipped in as nick fury during the blip
like before far from home i just feel
like
it would be so scrawl of them
that's how nick fury sounds uh i just
think he's doing a nick fury
racist
i'm not uh i just
this is the second time on this show
where i've been referred to as the
president
when was the first yesterday
he's as problematic as a peapod oh my
god i was gonna say i just don't think
that
and i mean check me if i'm wrong chat
and everyone here i just don't think
that nick fury would be in hiding during
the blip if he wasn't blipped you know
like i feel like he would have came out
you know what he could carry some ashes
in his pocket he just just screw him up
and like oh my god
underneath the jaw mother
i mean we saw those scenes of like
natasha and others like gathering to
like try to plan how to how to go about
things during the blip like it would be
terrible if he knew they were meeting
and he wasn't helping he was a prank
it's not even i don't think it's that he
would need a break i think it's also
that like sometimes nick is just like a
punk do you guys know what i'm talking
about like it's like without the help of
like um carol danvers and uh what's her
i always call her colby smolders what's
her character's name maria hill maria
hill it's kind of like he doesn't really
get too involved so i think having the
avengers that we did have in the blip or
outside of the blip are what they were
going to stick with nick fury what was
he going to add to it just be like
here's my talking point i can't
physically help you one thing that might
be interesting to consider is that in
the comic books you know nick fury is
old af
uh 616 comics nick fury you know he was
born
uh in the early 1900s he fights in world
war ii he's part of the howling
commandos he fights with captain america
and then during the war he's given i
think it's called like the infinity
formula or something which is not a
super soldier serum but it's something
that extends his life and allows him to
live
during the rest of the comics we don't
know that about our nick fury yet you
know we saw him in captain marvel and he
was a young up-and-coming shield agent
yeah he's lost some hair he's lost an
eye but like it's also like captain
america who starts aging much later
right
it could be that he you know when we see
him in uh captain marvel he's not he's
he's already like 60 years old or
something like that but he has some sort
of weird formula in him that would be a
weird thing for them not to have
mentioned in that feature-length film i
mean
why not he doesn't he doesn't tell
people about it it's a big point in the
comic books because like uh bad guys are
always trying to capture him to steal
the formula out of him because it's like
this mysterious thing uh so he could
have something that has extended his
life for longer and maybe that's what
we'll learn about i think like some of
the things he was saying i i'm really
anticipating this being kind of what we
were talking about how like they're now
able to explore different genres coming
of age action
comedy legal comedy whatever like i
think this is going to be hardcore
spycraft right this is going to be an
invasion yes it's going to be twists on
turns on double crosses on you don't
know who to trust like a real mission
impossible style are you guys really
excited yeah i know you're excited to
see griffin because you've been saying
that like everything is like
ben mendelsohn olivia coleman i'm the
only tamed person that's like yeah i get
i i'm more like
i will get hyped once i stop believing
that everyone is in a scroll i don't
like that everyone's just grown
everyone's just growing up
put up a super chat what if nick has
been dead since winter soldier and all
the other knicks are scrolls
they're all scrolls
girls they're all scrolls girls they're
all scrolls good winners they're all
scrolls this is not mandatory fun yet
also
if you wait uh i would love that that'd
be so sick um what that what the super
chat says
everyone just a scroll and he's been
dead i mean this is gonna be
you know having lived through battlestar
galactica on tv like this could be a
tough time where you're just accusing
everyone all the time of being a scribe
that's the thing that is gonna make me
so mad watching it it's just it's gonna
be everyone turning on themselves
because they're gonna be like who is
actually who that's the fun of a spy
series right you never know who's the
secret double agent this will be like
you never know who's a secret different
species right like it's gonna multiply
normal spy show hijinks by a thousand uh
speaking of multiplying you're fun by a
thousand we'd like to thank the sponsor
of today actually all week uh we're
being sponsored by our good friends at
baksu oh yeah
is a monthly subscription service that
delivers premium japanese snacks and tea
pairings straight from japan to your
door each month you get a cute little
box like this and those boxes feature uh
some kind of a theme providing a horny
journey to japan uh today we have the
i'm gonna mispronounce it the tanjubi
box tinjubia is japanese for birthday
and this is a box celebrating baksu's
sixth birthday as a company hey
congratulations happy happy birthday
to celebrate it they picked out like
truly the the top snacks from both their
staff and uh their their subscribers
there's a little peak now tommy and i
both got down with a couple this this
used to be my boxes this used to be a
little heavier box but tommy and i both
looted and polluted on it earlier i said
box it to me baby yeah i had the black
sesame cookie that was delicious as i
had a little mochi treat that was uh
also delicious tommy you guys i had a
tokyo baked base
chocolate banana like kind of like a
biscuit it was so good but let me tell
you the real mvp of today's game it was
this mochi truffle
and it had strawberry in the middle and
i had one and i fed phillip one off a
toothpick did samantha our co-worker had
one and we all agreed that if we ever
find these again we will not share
we will not we are we are a tree we are
a trio now of mochi truffle lovers and
we will not share our truffles uh these
boxes are truly filled with like we kind
of talked about it yesterday when we
pounded our way through one of them a
lot of little surprising tastes all
kinds of like unexpected treats that if
if you're in north america like we are
maybe you don't see these that often and
we're going to be sampling different
boxy boxes all day this week uh order
one send us a pic of you and uh your
loved ones popping open a box soon maybe
we'll share it on the show maybe mail
your mochi truffles that you don't want
me i'll give you my personal address uh
just find me on twitter yes uh yeah
people have been sending tell me all
kinds of fun pictures on twitter uh to
try boxing yourself and support new
rockstars click the link in this video's
description and use code rockstar so
r-o-c-k-s-t-a-r-s to get 15
off your order code rockstars the link
in the description thank you so much to
box too also we want a quick shout out
uh our merch partners over at epic hero
for their cool uh
cozies here that we're rocking on set um
these are called soup cans they're
available
on the um
uh
okay i've uh screwed up the prompter
they're available on the epic hero shop
brandon's gonna fix it and uh
yes check these out epic hero shop uh
i've ruined the script but you know what
tommy you know what i think time it is
hang on i hear a chime in the distance
oh fun fun fun fun
fun fun fun fun well let me check my
watch it must be time for mentor fun no
oh yes that giant clock that tells us a
when the world's gonna end and b
when mandatory fun happens so nice we
play it twice hit my graphic again
all right now it's time for mandatory
fun this segment we're world-class
philanthropist lover genius con oh this
is from yesterday's script of course
forces his three best friends to have
fun with him philip tried his best
yesterday but let's be honest you can't
teach an old dog a new trick
good effort phillip but it's time for
daddy to take over okay the man is back
all right now i know that this is mentor
fun but i thought today i'd make let's
make it just for me oh for the rest of
you it's pop quiz time
horrible at pop quizzes i'm gonna throw
you all a rigorous test of mcu knowledge
and really just marvel comics knowledge
and generous but generous in general but
bust out those white boards and by the
way for those of y'all being stingy with
the swear jar you want to see me drop an
f-bomb in this segment you got 18 more
dollars to fill up my men and my ladies
and my dudes and now it's down to things
immediate response that's called the
bechtel bump all right
this jar is going to be up to a thousand
by the end of this segment now
everybody hide your whiteboards from
each other because you all can't be
trusted yeah snakes in the grass first
question
in the movie doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness what color is dr
strange's cape cloak sentient cloak
sentient cape whatever the thing is
which doctor 616 strange i don't know
you answer the question uh you're
already messing this up okay
uh
all right and five four
three
two
one and reveal
i can't read what you put cherry reading
i put two i said six one six it's red
838 it's blue okay so you didn't specify
so i said maroon with a blue patch on
the back oh i also went with maroon
because i figured red wasn't clear
enough ah well all three of you are
wrong because i'm talking about defender
strange who wasn't wearing a cape yes
then why did you ask what color are the
k-pop oh i'm sorry the answers are zero
zero zero play the graphic again
where the [ __ ] graphic card
it says 87 it says 87.
[Music]
you're a dear friend and a confidant can
you zoom in on me john in relation to t
michael mike uh my thing says tommy
sucks because he's a liar yeah well you
know what tommy sucks that's sure that's
true we're getting that we're putting
that on merge oh my god i really took
the wind out of my sails
tommy's not too sensitive
except for where it counts oh okay go go
that's why tommy can't wear corduroys oh
god go those are those are cooked by 10
a.m tommy two squares too much rubbing
all right now
listen to me tommy tmi
tommy tmz let's do this question number
two okay in the marvel comics
what color
is the original color of beast's fur oh
in the marvel comics
what color
is the original color
of beast's fur
in five hold on
four
three
two
one and reveal i said oh you wanna go
for a zack well i said blue okay i'm
trying to catch on to your bit so i said
he doesn't have fur well i went with
brown
uh because before he gets takes the
serum he's a brown-headed guy
his hair would be brown but is he white
in the original comic
the beast does not take a serum he is a
man he's a man born with freakishly
large hands and feet yeah and superhuman
strength and he has no fur
so i'll accept brandon's answer of brown
hair because he has brown hair thank you
great so that's one to zero to zero to
zero but this is mandatory fun and i
haven't quite felt the fun yet and i
think the reason why is the normal
chemistry's not here and the reason i
have to say that
is because i suspect i'm not amongst my
three best friends what i suspect
i'm amongst my three best scrolls
that's right a scroll
none of you are the real people you
claim to be
you're three scrolls
and in order for me to believe that
that's not true you need to answer a
question now that only the real brand in
only the real jessica and only most of
the real zaks would know all right
brandon first question for you okay what
kind of underwear did you wear yesterday
yesterday yeah jessica your question
what's that special thing we say to each
other every night before we go to bed
zach your question
what's my favorite memory of you and i
okay
all right for underwear yesterday i know
this because i am brandon yeah uh i was
not here okay i was dealing with things
okay and i was not wearing underwear i
was going oh
that is shocking that is shocking that
you got that right jessica i said we
don't go to bed with a winky face
oh geez wow okay
because i thought for sure you guys were
skrulls but uh it appears you both got
the correct answer and zach
i said
brandon wore fruit of the loom
wait a second that is my favorite memory
of that time i walked in on brandon
doing that risky business sketch just
take those old records off the shelf
that's nuts so i guess none of you guys
are skrulls yeah that's tommy wait does
that mean where are you
oh my god wait where's that going
to take his chair so you know he's a
scroll is that why the other tommy left
earlier and then a skrull tommy came
we
in
so behind on our scroll
keeping up with you uh
can you scroll up on the uh uh
teleprompter it's very weird that he
just ran away when do squirrels just
walk right i guess they do run away once
they're caught oh yeah so um we have
some more uh headlines again that we're
gonna get too there's a lot of star wars
news that came out this week uh actually
kind of in the last 24 hours including
um uh oh we haven't gotten to it yet but
um
uh yeah ryan johnson
his trilogy is still on so i was the
director of the last jedi right a little
controversial they kind of took him off
making the subsequent star wars film but
supposedly still in development three
more star wars movies or at least the
second and third installment of those
star wars movies are coming they were on
the back burner but uh after knives out
two and three supposedly he's gonna get
back to it uh the same article also gave
us info on the upcoming disney plus star
wars series we know we already know
kenobi's coming out at the end of this
month and we learned that andor which
follows diego luna's character from
rogue one will be coming out this summer
which was kind of sooner than we thought
yeah uh we just don't know the exact day
and month but uh we're hoping for maybe
like a july august release maybe oh hey
guys sorry uh oh tommy's been sorry i'm
40 minutes late for the show and have
not been here at all
did everything go all right
you weren't late tommy you're actually
here at the beginning we watched the
she-hulk trailer we that wasn't me we
talked about nick fury i shared an
intimate moment oh i was uh taking a
long winter's nap
oh uh unfortunately if the prompter's
broken here's a hard copy of the script
okay well thank you as well um no that's
that's that's strange um we also uh well
i guess welcome back there's nothing
else they could have explained
yeah i mean like i said it's my bad i'm
sorry i fell asleep but uh i'm so you're
saying there was a whole tommy here
there's somebody that looked exactly
like you they were wearing the agatha
all along shirt and everything yeah huh
they accused us of being strong they did
are you saying that on this show there
was
a scroll
[Applause]
[Laughter]
when it's when it's a scroll confirmed
it's not quite there yet um
uh finally although he's taking a break
from making marvel movies after stepping
away from fantastic four uh spider-man
uh director john watts is reportedly
teaming up with homecoming co-writer
chris ford to develop an amblin instead
inspired star wars tv show now for folks
not in the know amblin is the one you
kind of walk slowly right well it is
that but it's also the banner under
which most of steven spielberg's filming
so usually when people say an amblin
style they're referring to
e.t goonies you know other kind of like
uh
kid focused even one could make a um
what was the jj abrams what's it called
16.
super eight super he's gonna say eight
millimeters that's a very different
movie super eight oh that's a that's a
really feel good film
stranger things is arguably amblin style
i i have a question uh this is this is a
pure question so if you know in the chat
or if any of you know were the aren't
the amblin aren't there actual amblin
star wars films aren't the ewok movies
weren't they co-produced by amblin that
all like wicket or yeah like i like the
the like the one that's like the little
girl that meets there's like two ewok
movies that were directed yeah yeah it's
video like wicked or
willow
willow is not a star wars movie there
are two ewok direct tv movies from the
80s that i think were co-produced by
amblin and i think that's more what they
mean that they were kind of like child
adventures like they were star wars
universe but they were definitely for
kids unlike the original star wars
movies that were made for 45 year old
men that live with their parents
uh yeah so i mean again this is just
early stages of development for this
series it's not slated or anything like
that but that's interesting and again
kind of as we see more star wars series
that will be a more diverse uh set of
properties as well so this is going to
be maybe a kid-focused one supposedly
they're casting notices for child actors
could be kind of fun speaking of
children because i'm the baby of the
show it's my segment it's break room
breakdown
today
we're looking at eric vos's video about
potential parents of the god bastet he
calls it bastet we call it bass and love
and thunder uh chrissy in the chat did
say super chatted an agent egyptian they
added the suffix of t to words to done
denote
i don't know how to read denote them as
feminine which gives an
sound ending sound bast for wakanda
bastet for egyptian eric's 100 correct
bass came first i'm going to say bass
i'm going to say bass play that clip
john
i think all of these gods representing
the diversity of faces across planets
are being summoned back to olympus in
this congress with zeus to respond to a
crisis gods are being slaughtered and
valkyrie now ruler of asgard and jane
now the bearer of mjolnir are among
these representatives as is bastet maybe
also the members of the inead maybe the
deity worshiped by the centaurian tribes
that's the race of yondu who also
appears in this trailer footage but i
also think this gathering is exactly
what gore the god butcher actually wants
so that he can assassinate as many of
them as possible in one strike
all right so i'll tell you right now
i disagree
i disagree and if you watch rogue theory
i say that a lot but i will say it on
the break room too so okay i disagree
but do we agree with eric do we think
that's this i almost always agree with
eric because he threatens me if i don't
okay so do we
agree with the idea well i think i think
i kind of agree with him but what what
do you what makes you think otherwise no
i'm just i don't think those are the
same locations i don't think where we
saw um mighty thor and where we saw
valkyrie is the same of olympus uh i
think we talked about it briefly behind
the scenes here that he could have been
talking to his people and turned and
there's valkyrie do you think they're on
a zoom and they set that up
i still am right or die i think and
maybe i will probably be wrong so maybe
not die i do think that that is new
asgard i think valkyrie and mighty thor
are new asgard and i know people are
like oh well new rise guard doesn't look
that high and mighty on the outside
doesn't mean the inside like
infrastructure doesn't look like are you
looking a lot mightier now and the
i mean cruise ships are coming in yeah
you're saying you're saying the photo
not the clip of zeus that's not new
asgard you're saying the photo yeah the
photo about that is is a new asgard i am
worried that's new asgard i i think that
that makes sense because it would have
like they would probably get the ornate
asgardian architecture done inside first
right it's easier to you know just put
some facades out there true some facades
out there just put a couple of you know
uh that could be like a medieval time
style yeah dine with them yeah i have
guardians
they have asgardians with them right
from asgard and all as guardians are
like strong live long
have like some sort of magical ability
so it's like they could have a
woodworker who's incredible no you're
saying that's not basque or bastet well
i don't know my question is is that a
statue no i think it's her i think it's
her we were talking about this too
because they also
her graphics don't like compared to
valkyrie i'm just a combin like two
brown-skinned people i was like this
looks like cgi person
i mean do you think it's kind of crazy
to reveal best in like a promo image no
they don't draw that much attention to
her we also don't know if if bass is
going to play much of a role in this
kind of might be a little more than a
chemo i'm going to oh sorry no i was
going to say if you're going to show off
zeus immediately i think it's okay to
show up interesting
the biggest evidence i'm going to
ride with eric on this
is that cornucopia grapes right between
valkyrie and what about
of olympus right there that is a classic
uh you know those old school you know
grecian urns and and uh still life
paintings always had a cornucopia you
get you get you know grapes dangled over
your mouth as you're you know laying out
there you don't think you're going to be
a gift you don't think it could have
been just a gift i i wonder if maybe
that was the invitation the cornucopia
of grapes yeah but also if you're
watching the show right now and you're
thinking would be a great gift to send
these guys we're dying for a cornucopia
all the time but i will say that i do
hong kong i will say that i do agree
with uh
hold for sound
for sound they're filming something next
door and they have heavy equipment going
by
i think that um i do agree with vos
where they're like this is the meeting
of all the gods that we've seen so far
why they're not why do the greek gods
have that much power like any for
instance the idiot seems like very much
like
people you saw that location they can't
home as many gods as
yeah the location that we saw in the
great pyramid that was for earth like
they they live in the celestial opera
it's like why would everyone listen to
the greek one it could be what about
just like the senate in star wars what
if it's a duly elected popular vote and
everybody zeus is just a popular guy
amongst all the other gods they elected
him as the speaker of the house yeah
whatever yeah right we also you can't
tell exactly from that angle there might
be other people at similar heights right
are we are we now after multiverse of
madness like are any of you on edge of
like okay this thing with zeus and this
entire thing we're going to lose these
gods very quickly like gore is going to
come in like russell crowe is going to
get his head cut off
two seconds he's gonna say like two
lines and then gore is just gonna yeah
we were talking about that at the
beginning of just like this isn't gonna
stay this the scene is just like a come
get a taste and then when you show up
they're all gonna get slaughtered and we
i don't know if we i said i agree that i
think it's going to be hercules as the
last man standing oh yeah we were like
hercules gonna be the last man standing
i think he's gonna come through i think
he's been slaughtering people they're
going to zeus to be like yo we need to
double down and zeus is like i'm afraid
an old man call himself the butcher of
gods and then he's going to butcher all
the gore shows up yeah because all the
gods are full of themselves and things
are the most powerful i think boss is
right with it can i can i can i say my
controversial prediction
someone that's going to say someone's
going to be killed
i think that we could see valkyrie yeah
no
i don't want to happen i love her i love
her
i write poems about her i don't know it
is interesting that jane foster's there
granted she is the god of thunder right
now but do you think valkyrie was like
yeah you better come too or do you think
jane has some sort
i don't know how much her mind has
changed where she's like no i need to be
there to protect you like i'm coming to
protect i think there's also if if
jessica's right and those are two
different scenes which i think there's a
decent chance that's the case that those
are two very different scenes maybe
as eric predicts that is zeus welcoming
a bunch of gods gore shows up slaughters
everybody that is later that is like a
war council later where maybe like
remaining gods gods that weren't at that
initial meeting are gathering around
because again those are serious faces
those are not like hey we're seeing all
our god buddies for the first time in a
long time oh great to check in yeah this
is like yeah oh the the s has already
hit the fan yeah we've got to figure out
what to do about this gorgeous 100 well
i certainly sorry i certainly hope she
doesn't die yes
you wished tommy wishing you found it on
death confirmed in the chat you guys
seem to agree with uh eric on this one
71 saying that the the meeting of the
gods is all part of gore's plan in the
4-4 trailer uh gore seems like a clever
guy
what have these got's done for me lately
someone's got a kill it's a real
godfather three kind of move you get all
the the leaders of the five families
together then you wipe them all oh
spoiler alert for four days oh and by
the way we call it the godfather coda
now because the godfather three people
immediately i ain't watching that
i've never seen it um oh here's a
uh charcoal chocobo kid has a fun super
chat i wonder if there's a council of
tommy's where it's always mandatory fun
no there is it's inside my head and it's
been clinically diagnosed
we do have a few super chats we can go
through as we're wrapping up the show
today uh charlie 836 going back to the
she-hulk trailers asking am i the only
one who thinks bruce is too brucy needs
a bit more of hulk's personality traits
let me know your thoughts yes you're the
only one let bruce be bruce oh that
brisby bruce what's interesting i i
wanted to say again we'll have both the
full reaction and a full breakdown of
the she-hulk trailer dropping on our
channel later this week probably within
the next 24 hours but i thought it was
interesting in the very first footage we
ever saw from she-hulk from last disney
plus day we saw mark ruffalo not hooked
up and now in a similar scene set in a
lab we see you hooked up and i don't
think we see a single mark ruffalo alone
shot in this trailer so like i wonder if
that was just a pre and post cgi maybe
or maybe in the series he does go back
and forth a little bit i'd be pissed if
i was mark ruffalo i'd be like i had to
go into hair and makeup that day you
just
you just see me out come on
brad van i agree john gabers for
hercules uh keep going or tommy no bring
in the rock as hercules
he's doing great john gabris would be a
great hercules and he's campaigned hard
for the role and that's why i'm gonna
snake him at the last minute which leads
into this other great super chat so
sarah masks will there be another fit
challenge this summer yes and it's gonna
be me training to be hercules oh
beautiful get behind you better hurry up
because i heard the movie's already been
shot
soon exactly uh jonas julius whose name
i always mispronounce you see him on the
discord a lot uh who do we think will be
the first on-screen scroll say that five
times fast revealed in the series my bet
is on hank pym phase four loves being
comic accurate i mean this is this is
gonna be
great father for the channel uh for many
many days yeah
don't you think in this series i think
we could see anybody has a scroll and
that's not saying they've been a scroll
the whole time that's like maybe maybe
hank pym revealed as a scroll then we
cut to the actual hank pym's trap down
he's asking he's asking like a comment
question where someone's been a scroll
for a while we've seen on film assume
that they were the actual person and it
turns out they were a scroll we can i
like maria hill being a scroll maria
give her give her that give her that
let's do let's do as many speed as my
favorite thing at conventions is when
they do speed questions which are like
yes or no a quick quick one from joe
bartoloni which are you related to tony
bartoloni of los angeles are you the
tick tocker that's really famous gotta
keep going uh and now that we're gonna
get an a mcu r-rated film with deadpool
what do you think uh we'll get an
r-rated star wars project or will we
ever i'm hoping for a red harvest style
force zombie whoa that's fine michael
hamilton spent ten dollars to ask us
david tennant and catherine tate have
been seen in set photos for the 60th
anniversary of doctor who what is the
level of excitement for this
announcement nothing nerd
nothing nerd no
but i support all doctor who fans and i
wish you the best because you guys have
to eat a lot of garbage
[Applause]
oh you're referring back to what i said
earlier no you don't yeah because you
can just watch eric boss break it down
and spoil it for you yeah and by the way
if you wear doctor who's stuffed to a
red fair you're doing it wrong okay it's
illegal don't cross the street stop uh
john adam asked would love to see them
bring in a nick fury senior like they
showed in the comics uh i let's get
someone to be nick fury's dad i'm i
could do it i'm down for that yeah uh
and also bring back as you're bradley
why you're right yeah you're more old oh
i need more elijah bradley
said shout out to fun facts chrissy love
you guys after a couple of years of
following this channel it's awesome we
get to talk to you guys live big hip
gang oh my gosh
we do love talking to you guys
come on
elizabeth asks who do you think will be
the most interesting to be revealed
you said maria two people asked that
question it looks like everyone wants to
know most interesting to be revealed to
be a squirrel happy hogan happy hogan
confirmed
dating on aliens yeah i mean we know
emma's not a skrull because we did watch
the life leave her face and she did not
convert back to us that doesn't
remember they autopsied and they found
oh this guy's got too many parts you
when you're transferred as a scroll and
you die you stay okay you were you stay
corrected that'd be nice because i i
would like some more marisa tomei in my
life yeah
i don't care if she's an alien bring her
back michael gallego says is deadpool
going to be the next in the next thor
i don't know mike you watch the movie
okay and then you tell us
everything for you tommy's turned sour
too much time
tommy has soured the normally uh lovely
and friendly tommy has a flip to switch
weight maybe all of that was the
previous tommy wait was the scroll tell
me the nice thing about the scrolls
this is a great mental exercise to
conduct maybe with your loved one if you
found out they were a shape-shifter this
whole time but they were actually the
shape-shifter version of your loved one
was better than the normal version of
your loved one would you want to stick
with the shapeshifter version
we know that shape shifters zach's
number one fear he is so afraid that his
wife is the scroll right now he's
apparently i it does give me cold sweats
uh but you know what does it give me
cold sweats all our wonderful viewers
thank you so much for watching uh we're
gonna get to the bottom of tommy's
biology and what his
true species of origin might be uh we'll
we'll report back on that tomorrow he
started talking to us mike
tomorrow in the break room we'll be back
at roughly the same time we might have
some more disney plus news to report on
who knows uh who knows what kind of
other trailers they might drop in the
interim uh we thank you uh we appreciate
you we'll talk to you tomorrow